yeah speaking of coffee machines i uh i
found this [ __ ]
so like aki's quite obsessed with
tick-tock okay
as as most people are like these days
yeah and
like i don't have like because i don't
have tick-tock install on my phone right
my only exposure to tick-tock yeah
and uh and this [ __ ] thing where
you know those like [ __ ] tick tocks
where it's like amazon gadgets that
changed my life part 71 like you know
those
[ __ ] they all sound the [ __ ] same
there was one where it was literally
this
alarm clock all right it's 400 bucks it
was this alarm clock
that makes you a cup of coffee oh we had
when it went
yeah we had that in the like 80s in the
uk for tea really yeah it was called a
cattleman
and uh you could set the alarm and it
would pour
this is not a new invention tick tock
[ __ ] yeah so it's like it was like
there's like a [ __ ]
it looks like maybe it's about that big
that's pretty massive it's pretty
[ __ ] large but there's like you know
the
the cup the coffee mug there and then
there's like a proper brewing
thing on the side and you put in this
like canister of milk in the morning
right like lock it in and when the alarm
goes off it just straight up just makes
you a [ __ ] like
an espresso machine is literally one
button you could literally have that
next to your bed
you don't need yeah exactly that's what
i was thinking i was like
just get a [ __ ] nespresso machine and
just put the [ __ ] thing in and
do it yeah so please just sponsor us
already yeah like
like like because the problem is right i
i feel like nespresso
is one of the best capsule machines but
i feel like in japan it's the only
capsule machine it's
actually good because the like you could
get like the actual
uh you know the ones that actually have
to put the uh the coffee um
grinded the beans right yeah like i had
one of those
i had one of those as well
yeah like nespresso is like the perfect
i'm literally just [ __ ] marketing to
you right now yeah it is literally the
easiest
and like easiest to clean it's just easy
for the quality you get and for the
convenience it is
the best capsule machine please
sponsored
a lot of capsule machines
we bought one just for this office it
was literally the first purchase that we
made
and we tried to get geeks plus to play
for it for us but they wouldn't allow it
so we played before we bought this table
we bought the nespresso machine
we had our priorities right that's for
sure exactly yeah i remember when they
gave us the spreadsheet of just like
okay
so they get so geeks plus gave us a
spreadsheet because they said they would
help
us um dick not decorate the office but
refurbish the office yeah and we were
like okay
tables desk television um not my story
[Music]
no no but there was a it was it was
split up in like here's the list of uh
like here's the list of the things we
need and here's the list of the things
we want and we put
the espresso machine in the first thing
on need
we're like no you don't understand yeah
we need this
was like do you really need this is this
as necessary
as the table and we were like yes yes
without without coffee this podcast is
not happening no i'm sorry
i'm not i'm not going to film yeah i
refuse to release episodes
because like another thing about
japanese like coffee shops as well is
that there are so many
independent coffee shops here in japan
so if you're ever coming to japan you
you can walk down a random street and
find like
five to ten different like indie coffee
shops and the problem is they all look
[ __ ] great
yeah they do but it's such a coin flip
on whether
it's going to be good coffee or not
because the the
like the fallacy is that you know it's
i've like some of the best and poshes
looking coffee shops i've been to in
japan
have just had the [ __ ] as coffee yeah
it's like acid yeah
it's like dirt water like because i
remember like uh especially in like
central tokyo like nishiazabu
and like um stuff like that there's like
a lot of like
really like fancy kind of like rustic
looking coffee shops where
the beans are all lined up and they got
like they got the aesthetic down they
got the aesthetic to a tea yeah
and then you order it and you're like
waiting for this cup of coffee for like
20 minutes
they're like what are they picking the
[ __ ] coffee beans yeah off the plant
like it's taking so long
and what comes out is like [ __ ] yeah and
essentially
it's it's just like dirt water sometimes
because it's like twelve dollars please
yeah and
yeah he's [ __ ] twelve dollars for
like this one yeah i i thought like
because especially going to america or
something you order like a cup of coffee
and you just assume that it's refillable
right
it's that kind of level of quality but
in japan you can have like
the [ __ ] like instant coffee dirt
water
and they give it to you in this like the
poshest little cup and it's [ __ ] tiny
it's 12
and you're just there being like i'm
even more depressed than i was
before i ordered this coffee that's why
it's sad right it's sad that like blue
bottle coffee and starbucks are like the
best coffee in japan
it really is it's like going to you know
any foreign you know mcdonald's is the
finest cuisine yeah
literally the best like don't eat
anything like it's so sad
the foreigners did it better than you
yeah and they're [ __ ] chains
just like oh you want you want some good
fried chicken well
i know a place it begins with a k
it's got my favorite kernel in front of
it